it is seven o'clock which means you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster a blueprint for a
green revolution
the government is setting out its vision
for the world's first
low-carbon industrial sector the aim of
cutting
industrial emissions by a third in 15
years we'll be asking the business
secretary quantity court saying about
that
in just a moment but also this morning
swapping torture and persecution in
north korea
for local government in greater
manchester we'll be speaking to the
defector hoping to become a conservative
councillor in berry
at 20 tonight but also on the programme
all the times you sort of miss with
someone and you should just
just do it shouldn't you remembering
caroline flack will be speaking to the
director of the new documentary looking
at the life
and death of the television presenter it
is
wednesday the 17th of march
[Music]
stealing a march on the rest of the
world's prolific burglars will be made
to wear gps tags
to crack down on reoffending we
know where they are at all times for a
year we'll help them stay on the
straight narrow
and help us catch up with them if they
don't
the ugly sides of the beautiful game
victims hope for justice
ahead of the publication of a delayed
report into football's child sex abuse
scandal
me personally there's only one word that
i wanted i didn't want 900 pages i just
wanted the word sorry
in the driving seat new employment
rights for 70 000
uber workers from today following a win
at the supreme court
not exactly plain sailing p and o
cruises say that unvaccinated
holidaymakers
won't be welcomed on trips this summer
chile for north sea coastal counties
today with some rain coming into eastern
and southeast england later
otherwise there will be some sunshine
quite warm in that as well
more details coming up before half-past
morning all burglars robbers and thieves
released from prison
will be made to wear gps tags to track
their movements
in a new initiative targeting
neighborhood crime
more than half of those convicted of
theft and burglary reoffend within a
year
nearly 80 percent of cases result in no
suspect being identified
the government scheme is the first of
its kind in the world
and will launch next month in six police
force areas
sania chowdhury has our first report
every morning tony anthony opens his
deli with nearly the same routine
but on may 4th four years ago this place
was a crime scene
i found this door against its hinges
open out on the pavement area
bent like an s banana the police never
caught the men who burgled tony's deli
even though they told him they knew who
they were
there's been a lot of rep repeat
burglaries in the area
um but unfortunately they have to catch
them in the act
in order to charge them and on that
evening
they were not caught
now new technology to crack down on
neighborhood criminals
burglars thieves and robbers who have
served a year or more in prison will be
fitted with a tag
when they're released this will monitor
their whereabouts using gps satellites
24 hours a day for up to 12 months we
know where they are at all times for a
year we'll help them stay on the
straight narrow
and help us catch up with them if they
don't the government hopes this will be
a vital
extra source of intelligence to help
police catch persistent offenders
sits as part of what we call integrated
offender management
i say where we're working with offenders
making sure that the three pillars of
success in their lives
so having a job having a home and having
a friend you know someone to hold their
hand
are in place along with the tagging
program to make sure that we
we break the cycle of reoffending it's a
world first but there are challenges
the technology isn't foolproof burglars
are very adept at working their way
around it i'm not going to broadcast how
that is
there's also another aspect of course
that the tag is visible
and it may it may be either a badge of
honor or it may be a stigma i don't know
people may be actually ashamed of
walking the streets
with a tag on because they're basically
highlighting i am a criminal
more than half of people convicted of
theft and burglary reoffend within a
year
and almost 80 percent of cases result in
no suspect being identified
just like in tony's case he spent over
two thousand pounds on reinforcing
security
the government hopes the tagging system
will save the taxpayer
billions of pounds sadia chowdhury sky
news in manchester
also this morning the government is
committing a billion pounds
to create the world's first low-carbon
industrial sector
as they outline spending to slash
emissions from industry schools and
hospitals the blueprint is aimed at
helping the uk reach the target of net
zero by
2050. with the government saying it will
also help to create
80 000 jobs across the country over the
next
three decades very pleased to say the
business secretary quasi quanting joins
us once again
on the program mr carting great to see
you this morning so do tell us
just a little bit about this this latest
phase in the green revolution
i think it's really important uh to
remember that we were the first
major industrial country to legislate
for the net zero
carbon emissions target that was two
years ago and this
uh measure actually is going to drive
our commitments to net zero by saying
the industrial sector all the industry
that we
produce are manufacturing as well
process
will actually conform with net zero
we're going to reduce
carbon emissions uh we've got great
ambitions
in this area but all the time we're
thinking about creating jobs
uh creating new industries and also
attracting inward investments
lots of people are very interested in
our ideas in our leadership
in fighting climate change it is
slightly away from your brief but
clearly the focus in all of this is is
the industrial element of things but but
what about
domestic what what about homes i mean
the climate change committee suggests
that we need an additional 3 billion
pounds a year if we're going to hit that
net zero target 3 billion on top of the
three billion we already spent
but all aimed at that kind of domestic
setting
yeah i think the domestic sector is uh
clearly very challenging
we've got lots of housing stock that we
want to retrofit make more
uh energy efficient and there are a
number of schemes
uh that are promoting that we've
committed also to the
in the manifesto to billions of pounds
over the next 10 years
to make sure that homes and public
buildings as well
are retrofitted and made more energy
efficient so that we can reduce
uh those common emissions how are you
going to restore the confidence
of the business community after you know
you essentially bend the industrial
strategy
that everyone was working on it's it's
not a question of
uh binning it uh neil what i've said
repeatedly is that that industrial
strategy was in
2017 came out in october 2017. i
remember it well
and a lot of things have happened since
october 2017. we've had a brexit deal
we've had kovitz 19 which nobody knew
about obviously in 2017
and we've also got the net zero
legislation that i've just been talking
about so
the world of 2021 is very different and
everyone could see that the industrial
century uh needed refreshing
so then the debate became about what
were we going to call it and we decided
to rebrand it
uh to meet the new challenges that we
face
uh minister just on your brief as well
some some news this morning about the
gig economy directly relating to that
supreme court decision about uber
you know there are 70 000 drivers now
getting guaranteed minimum wage holiday
pay pensions
well related to the time that they're on
less interest
in the specifics about the uber case but
is this is this the start of kind of
better regulation within within the gig
economy if so i mean is that
is that something that you're entirely
sanguine with
absolutely uh to be welcomed i've always
said i think even
on a program like this i've always said
the the new phase of our economy should
be about protecting workers rights
driving uh higher standards uh driving
new technologies uh in the way that we
were talking about earlier
and i think that uh the government's
record on things like the national
uh living wage uh that we introduced uh
has been very good
uh and we want to see a well-paid uh
workforce
with strong worker protections driving
innovation
and economic progress and i think that's
something that we can we can achieve
i i do want to ask you about a story
relating to to your colleague the
foreign secretary dominic rabb a leaked
conversation that he had with business
where he said i squarely believe we
ought to be trading liberally around the
world
if we're restricted to countries with
echr convention and human rights level
standards of human rights
we're not going to do many trade deals
with the growth markets of the future
should we be dealing with people at all
who are in breach of
you know generally accepted standards of
human rights
i think that the foreign secretary is
right uh we should be
uh trading with uh countries but at the
same time we've got to make very strong
representations as we do
when we think that countries are
mistreating minorities
using torture and not sharing our values
but what we can't do
is simply say you know right cut whole
countries off
and refuse to engage while telling them
uh how how to run their own countries
we've got to
uh be flexible and in the international
context
we've got to trade but also yeah i
understand that but
the foreign secretary also in the
conversation said this you know i can
think of behavior that would that would
cross the line
and render a country beyond the pale so
i'm just wondering
where that line is drawn i mean it's not
about for example
the genocide of the uyghur muslims we're
still carrying on our trade with china
you know it doesn't relate to saudi
arabia you know we've been dealing them
weapons which we know have been used in
the conflict in yemen
we maintain trade with the united states
a country which is a history of
executing mentally ill criminals i'm
just wondering where the line is
i'm not sure what you're suggesting that
we stopped trade with the united states
i mean that that seems like a bizarre
suggestion
but i'm asking where he said the foreign
secretary said i can think of behavior
that would cross the line and render a
country beyond the pale
where is the line i agree with what the
foreign secretary said
about trade i think you obviously have
to take
each circumstance as it comes
i think that there are serious issues
with china
and we've made representations to them
our ambassador
is doing a great job and in fact she's
been mentioned
uh not all together favorably by the
chinese government we're always making
representations to governments to treat
people fairly
and to observe standards in human rights
sure but just in terms of okay we goes
to the integrated uh the integrated
review that was published in the commons
yesterday there is clearly a strategic
difference between the way that we are
dealing with russia and china
i'm just wondering what what the
justification for that difference is
given that there is abundant evidence
that the chinese authorities
have been part of a genocide of the
weaker muslim community
you're absolutely right neil and what
i've tried to say is that our ambassador
in china has made really strong
representations to the chinese
government
about the uh their behavior and we've
said
uh that we don't find this remotely
acceptable
and we're trying to make a international
calls
alliances to make those representations
to the chinese government we're
absolutely very firm on that
at the same time we are
attracting chinese investment if you go
to a city like sheffield you'll see
lots of chinese investment coming into
into this country but you've got to
distinguish between investors
private citizens people that we trade
with and
actual governments can i just um
finish our time this morning minister by
talking about about covert 19 and
and this morning the guardian has a
rather big piece about
you know where we are where we've been
and where we're going now
we had a promise from the prime minister
that there would be an inquiry into
the government's handling of covid19
that promise was given in july we still
don't have a date for that
i know when i'm getting my next haircut
on april the 12th
we don't know when this inquiry is going
to start given we've got something of a
road map in place
isn't now about time for you to start
moving forward with this
well look i think lots of people have
different views about this
personally i think that what we have to
do is get through
the road map i think we've got to reopen
the economy and then once
the economy's uh reopened once we've got
through
the worst of the pandemic and it's still
with us um we can have a debate
and i'm sure that there'll be plenty of
room for an inquiry but we haven't it
seems
premature to launch an inquiry when the
the pandemic is still
all around us i i i i completely
i completely agree but at the same time
we know that by the other side of the
summer according to the road map
things should be pretty much back to
normal and going by the data that's
presented going by the evidence that the
government scientists have put forward
it seems we're on track for that it does
rather feel like
you yourself are suggesting that inquiry
could get started
some point this year certainly the other
side of the summer
well all i'm saying is that we should
wait and see this process through we've
got a road map
we've got various dates uh i think the
next significant date is april the 12th
when non-essential retail will be
opening up and all i'm saying is that
we've got to try and get through
that process reopen the economy see what
the effects the medium-term effects of
covid
have have been look at the employment
situation and then i'm sure there'll be
plenty
of room and plenty of appetite for a
full inquiry as to
what happened certainly in terms of the
appetite quantity quarting great to see
you this morning thanks for watching
thank you
plenty more coming up on the show this
morning we're going to be getting
labour's take
on the controversial policing and crime
bill the shadow justice secretary david
lammy will be joining us
at five past eight
we'll be talking to the mayor of county
waterford about his call to celebrate
saint patrick's day at home
for a second time that's at 20 past
eight
and at half past that i'll be asking the
president of piano cruises
about the chances of setting sale on
holiday
this summer
but now the football association will
today release a report
into decades of child abuse in the sport
more than four years after it was
launched in the wake of an avalanche of
accusations by
former players the report by clive
sheldon qc
delayed several times we'll look at how
the fa clubs
and individuals handled reports of abuse
made to them
between 1970 and and make
recommendations on safeguarding
sky sports correspondent martha counter
reports
it's been over four years since andy
woodward revealed horrific abuse by
pedophile coach barry bennell
now are we about to finally discover the
full extent of the game's sex abuse
scandal the fa's independent report is
expected to be
at least 700 pages long and detail the
abuse of hundreds of boys
by dozens of coaches spanning four
decades
it will make a judgment about whether
football's darkest secret
was covered up 900 pages
seems a lot but there's only one word
me person there's only one word that i
want i didn't want 900 pages i just
wanted the word sorry
in november 2016 andy woodward revealed
he was sexually abused as a child by
former coach barry bonnell
later that month several clubs including
crew alexandra manchester city and
chelsea
launched independent reviews into
historic abuse
in december 2016 the fa began an
independent inquiry led by barrister
clive sheldon qc
in february 2018 barry bonnell was
jailed for 30 years for 50 counts of
child sexual abuse
the release of clive sheldon's report
has been delayed several times
which survivors say was deeply upsetting
now they fear a watered-down document
which doesn't punish the adults who
failed to report the abuse
this report is likely to trigger an
apology from the football association
what it will also look at is whether
there was any conspiracy within the game
or at least whether there was any
collusion between abusive coaches
bob higgins was sentenced to 24 years in
jail in 2019 for abusing boys at
southampton football club
there is evidence to suggest he also
knew barry bernell
some victims believe there was a
pedophile ring in football
but it's thought the report does not
arrive at that conclusion
for the survivors it's not just been
four years waiting for this report
but in many cases decades waiting for
justice
now hoping football doesn't fail them
again
martha kellner sky news now let's take a
look at a couple of the other stories at
making the news this morning
the majority of the public think the
police were right to break up the vigil
being held in memory of sarah everard on
saturday
that according to a survey from yougov
which found 53 percent of people in
general
and 56 of men agreed with the police
actions
but most 18 to 24 year olds disagreed
they said the mets were wrong to behave
in the way they did
at least eight people have been killed
and another has been injured in a series
of shootings in the u.s city of atlanta
uh the attacks took place in three spas
to the northeast of the city with
reports that a number of the victims are
asian
a 21 year old man has been arrested in
connection with the incident
police are still determining if the
shootings are related
scotland's first minister nicolas
sturgeon has been asked to
explain fresh allegations of
interference by her chief of staff
and a sexual misconduct investigation
the conservative mp david davis used
parliamentary privilege in westminster
to allege that civil servants exchanged
messages suggesting that
liz lloyd was interfering in the
complaints process against mr simond
he said the message was sent on the 6th
of february 2018. that's
two months before mr sturgeon told
parliament she first learned of the
complaints
tiger woods says he will continue his
recovery from a car crash
at home after announcing his departure
from hospital
amass woods underwent surgery on open
fractures to his lower right leg and
further injuries to his foot and ankle
following the crash in los angeles last
month
the 15-time major winner tweeted saying
i'm so grateful for the outpouring of
support
and encouragement that i've received
over the past
few weeks
the u.s president joe biden has said new
york's governor andrew cuomo should
resign from his position
if the state attorney general's
investigation confirms the
sexual harassment allegations against
him mr biden made the comments in an
interview with abc news which is due to
air tonight saying
mr cuomo would slightly be prosecuted if
the allegations were proven true
governor cuomo for his part denies
allegations that he sexually harassed or
behaved
inappropriately towards multiple women
uber drivers in the uk are to receive
the national living wage
pensions and holiday pay from today
after the ride-hailing app lost a
case at the supreme court last month
more than 70 000 drivers who are now to
be treated as workers
under uk employment law are now in line
for the benefits let's speak to our
correspondent
uh ali fortescue who joins us this
morning good to see you ali
i suppose this is this is certainly good
news for many many uber drivers
but it doesn't go entirely as far as
some of them would have wanted
yeah that's right and there are still
concerns about things like the
entitlements only lasting
from the moment that the passenger gets
into the vehicles
and the ending when the passenger leaves
the vehicle that is something
that the drivers that were behind that
court battle have already raised
concerns about
of course i think we all remember that
long court battle was called a david and
goliath battle about whether those
workers should be classed
as workers or contractors culminating of
course as you say in the supreme court
with a victory
for the uber drivers as you say they
will now be entitled
to the national living wage which is
eight pounds
72 an hour they'll also automatically be
enrolled into a pension scheme
and get holiday pay based on how much
they enter those are the basic rights
that are now
enshrined in uk law that uber say will
come into force
from wednesday um but as i say the
drivers that were behind that have
welcomed it but still
some concerns worth saying uber say this
is an important day but the unions say
that whilst it was
the right thing to do it is a shame they
say that uber as they
were dragged kicking and screaming to
get here
so yes i think the debate about the
specific rights when it comes to these
uber drivers will roll
on but whatever way you look at it this
is a significant moment for those 70
000 uber drivers in the uk and will
undoubtedly have a knock on
impact for the gig economy more widely
thanks ali
dominic cummings remember him uh well
he's going to be giving evidence this
morning in front of the old party
science and technology select committee
um excuse me it's the first time that
the former downing street
de facto chief of staff has appeared
since his dramatic exit from number 10
in november last year
our political correspondent tom raynor
is here in the studio
morning tom i i thought dominic cummings
generally resisted
calls to appear in front of select
committees well he did didn't he
back in 2018 he was held in contempt of
parliament for not contributing
and attending a select committee hearing
on disinformation but he is
going to be giving evidence today on
arya that is
the advanced research and invention
agency that the government recently
announced widely seen to be his
brainchild if you like it's modeled on
darpa which is an advanced research
program in the us
and really that is something that
dominic cummings i imagine would want to
be his political
legacy it's about funneling money into
areas where other
normal research funding wouldn't
necessarily
go for it because it would be a gamble
things might not pay off but if they did
it's described as funding
high-risk high-reward projects
but clearly there are going to be all
sorts of questions that the
members of parliament will want to ask
he is after all uh
more famous than most of the cabinet as
a result of his role in vote leave as a
result
of uh the notorious lock down breaking
trip
uh to barnard castle as a result of the
45 000 pound pay increase that he was
given
uh quietly at the start of uh 2020 which
we only found out about really when he
left
uh number 10 in the midst of that highly
controversial
uh political infighting that was going
on in
downing street so it'll be very
interesting neil at 9 30
to see how far uh the mps limit their
questions
uh the scope of those questions onto
arya
or whether or not they're tempted to
stray somewhat i think they might just
tom for now thanks very much indeed
and you can see mr cummings appearance
in front of the science and technology
committee here on sky news breakfast
that will be coming your way just
actually just before
half past nine
uh but some other stories making
headlines today renewed calls for
information have been
issued to mark the 12th anniversary of
the disappearance of the chef
claudia lawrence miss lawrence was
reported missing in march
2009 after failing to turn up for a
shift at the university of york
police believe the then 35 year old was
murdered
but her body has never been found
elsewhere this morning the foreign
secretary will demon that democracy is
in retreat around the world as he sets
out why the uk still has a major role to
play on the global stage
dominic rabb will use a speech to argue
that democracies face their greatest
threat since the end of the cold war
he'll also stress the need for the uk
to use its military economic diplomatic
and cultural clout
to be a force for good in the world
mcdonald's has started an investigation
after staff in kent
merseyside and greater manchester
restaurants told sky news
that stores have been repeatedly
breaking their own health and safety
rules
during the winter wave of covered dante
the fast food chain said the accounts
were deeply concerning
and vowed to ensure that robust safety
measures were in place
and being followed
p and o cruises say that holidaymakers
will have to
will have to prove they've had both
doses of a coronavirus vaccine
it comes as the hospitality industry
braces itself for the end of a difficult
12 months
due to coronavirus lockdown restrictions
major companies operating in the uk may
have been
complicit in the forced labor of china's
uighur minority
that according to a new report mps on
the business energy and industrial
strategy committee say
many firms can't guarantee that they're
not linked with modern slavery there
warning that the government should crack
down on forced labour
and blacklist companies who can't show
clean
supply chains let's speak now to our
asia correspondent
tom cheshire who's in beijing morning
tom
just explain exactly how these uighur
muslims are how we believe these weaker
muslims are
are being used and the potential effects
that there could well be on
large parts of the british supply chain
i mean just to remind you of the whole
situation
um lots of reports uh credible reports
are giving to the uk government of the
mass detention
of the uyga minority in northwest china
and xinjiang province the other part of
that
is those minorities being allegedly
forced to work in camps on all sorts of
goods
including cotton but also electronics um
lots of reports
on that this is something china denies
and says is
a lie but this committee was looking at
how those products from xinjiang might
end up
in the uk asking all sorts of companies
for their supply chain details and
concluding that
no company especially in the fashion
industry was able to guarantee
that their products did not contain uh
materials partly sourced
from xinjiang they thought that was
astonishing
after so long a time with all these
reports and they went on to make
recommendations in a report that's very
critical of the government first it says
as you say they should come up with two
lists actually a white list for
companies that have taken steps to try
and ensure their supply chains
don't include forced labor and a
blacklist for those companies that
haven't done that
and second they say the government
should re-examine applying sanctions to
chinese officials
complicit in human rights abuses they
say this is something the u.s has done
and it's astonishing that the uk
government hasn't done
the same this is all in the context of
course the defense review which wanted
to deepen
economic links with china that was the
government's position this is parliament
putting pressure on the government
to take a tougher stance tom many thanks
time for us to see how the weather is
looking this wednesday
uh isabel is here with the details
morning isabel give me some good news
well yesterday was amazing uh nearly 16
degrees in edinburgh
neil and about uh what nearly uh 18
celsius in the west midlands yesterday
very good indeed
what would it be like today let's take a
look
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
early fog lifting and there will be
plenty of sunshine again today some
really nice weather
thanks to high pressure a lot of settled
uh weather but there will be some rain
just coming down the eastern side of the
country
so it might look all right now but cloud
will thicken across eastern england
and we will find that some rain
gradually pushes in through the course
of the day so a bit disappointing is
that rain closes in on
for example yorkshire lincolnshire for a
time into east anglia in the southeast
as well that's probably where it would
be most extensive at lunchtime
and a bit of a cool breeze for that east
coast as well elsewhere the sun becomes
really quite widespread across scotland
after a fairly cloudy start
and then you just join in really with a
good part of northern england wales
the south west and ireland and
temperatures in a few spots
getting up to about 15 to 17 degrees the
northwest clouds over later
and the southeast thankfully dries up
for a time
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
israel thank you still to come this hour
could the
full extent of child sex abuse and
english football
be about to be revealed
[Music]
so
[Music]
we should protect our heritage
unfortunately it will become part of
azerbaijan
this monastery is under the protection
for now the next five years at least of
russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magni and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
i witnessed the despair of the armenians
in nagorno-karabakh who were digging up
the soil of their dead relatives
it's armenians who've abandoned these
villages now
despite what their strategy is i'm not
sure but they have made
some arrests already today
they can't kill everyone they can't
shoot everyone they
they can't arrest everybody
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
i mean this clearly says i love hitler
are you saying that doesn't say hitler
[Applause]
[Music]
russia insists that its military buildup
in the arctic is purely defensive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the business secretary
quasi quarten told the program
that now is not the time to launch an
inquiry into the government's handling
of covert 19. it comes as some senior
doctors scientific advisors and the
former head of the civil service have
come together
to speak out in favor of a public
inquiry but mr quarting told me it was
premature to do so whilst the pandemic
was still ongoing
personally i think that what we have to
do is get through uh the road map i
think we've got to reopen the economy
and then once the economy's uh reopened
once we've got through
the worst of the pandemic and it's still
with us um we can have a debate
uh and i'm sure that there'll be plenty
of room for an inquiry but we haven't it
seems
premature to launch an inquiry when the
pandemic is still
all around us
uh let's bring you a little bit more now
on the imminent release of the sheldon
report
into historical sex abuse in football
uh pleased to say joining us on the
program we've got the former newcastle
united
midfielder and survivor of abuse at
derrick bell
derrick great to have you on the
programme this morning um
just just for for our viewers just if
you can
and in as little or as much detail as
you wish to go
to just tell us a little bit about your
story and and the horror that you
experienced
several decades ago yeah it was a
quite a traumatic time um i was abused
by
my abuser for over four years
as a child and eventually went to court
in 2002
he was jailed for six years and
um it has had a big impact on my
my life uh i didn't tell anybody
about it my family my friends or anybody
for a lot of years so
it has been really in the background of
what i went through and eventually
when i confronted my abuser in 2000
and he apologized for what he did
and i used that evidence tape evidence
to go to the northumbria police
it resulted in the court case in 2000
and he was jailed for six years
and then obviously on the back of andy
woodward
coming forward uh i
waved my in 2016
in support of other ex-professional
footballers
i wanted to help andy and
like to paul stewart david white come
forward steve walters and i thought
i was in a good place at that time to
not about me but to try and make sure
that this
prolific pedophile um was
was put away that started a new
investigation in 2016
and he was jailed for 20 years in 2018
of that trial in newcastle crown court
over
40 witnesses came forward since myself
and david
dock from the northeast um
went to the police and raised concerns
about
george ormond um derek we're going to
talk in a second about about
the sheldon report with with one of the
lawyers who's been working
in in abuse cases but i just wonder if
you can
just speak to our audience just a little
bit about what it is like to be a young
boy
you know with the future laid out in
front of him
you know doing playing football with his
friends
at a club where you know he thinks sees
a future i mean
so many of your dreams were coming true
at that point i presume
and you had this horrific abuse
taking place at the same time
yeah it was it was very very difficult
it was like anybody living in newcastle
they wanted to play for the hometown
club
and i was no different from the age of
10 kicking
the ball around in the back streets of
the west end of newcastle
and i joined the boys club where omar
would have
hoping that he would help me
fulfill my career he obviously grew my
parents to the extent where he got into
my house
and at the time i was young i knew it
was wrong
but his his his threat was
if i didn't perform sexual acts on him
or
him or me he he wouldn't make me a
professional footballer
and for somebody 11 12 year old to have
that dream taken away from him
i just hit it i managed to
eventually fulfill my dream in 1983.
i made a first team of parents for
newcastle
and it was fantastic time
38 000 that's in james's park with
kevin keegan in the side and terry
mcdermott some of my
childhood heroes so it was a absolute
dream to
fulfill my what potential
if you like to make the first team
unfortunately an angie
could tell my career but in the back of
that
was always george ormond you know the
nightly waking up
sweating um just
awful dreams about the abuse
but i tried to keep it in the back of my
mind
until 1995 um
after trying to end my life i was
sectioned
under the mental health act some 20
20 odd years later i then
sort of disclosed that i'd been abused
by a child
as a child horrific times during them
yes
and even over the past what
10 years since the trial in 2002
i still have nightmares um so it's not
just
myself it impacted on it impacted on
my behaviors my my relationships
um and the impact on my family they felt
the guilt but it was not them that was a
fault
it was uh the abuse that i had suffered
um has a real impact on on my
my well-being i'm lucky to see i'm
in a good place at the present time and
2016
hopefully with the sheldon report coming
out we'll
hopefully look at some of the issues
that were not around
at the time of myself and others who
have
come forward with historic child abuse
take note um derek i just want to bring
in at this point
and introduce to her to our viewers uh
dino noche velli
a lawyer who's come specialized in in
abuse cases daniel thanks
thanks very much for being being on and
i don't know how much of derrick
derek's testimony you were able to hear
there but you've worked with a number of
survivors of
of this type of abuse and and i know
that you will know just how
how important it has been to hear
testimony
and testimony like this i mean what what
do you hope that we hear
uh or what results from the sheldon
report today
what my clients and all survivors want
is to finally hear the truth
actually as to how did this happen and
how did it happen for so long
in so many different clubs for so many
different years and how
did no one know about it and also to
learn the lessons we need to make sure
that we never
have another derek bell never andy
woodward
and those hundreds of survivors who have
bravely come forward
we need to have listened to them acted
on it and to make change it's so
important
what level of confidence do you have do
you know that that changes have been
made
institutional changes will be made at
the highest level all the way down to
the grassroots
hundreds of thousands of course we're in
the middle of a covered 19 pandemic an
organized sport for kids is
has has not been going on but you know
when it resumes we have tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of kids
who are involved in sports clubs how how
confident are you that these days they
are much safer than
than derek was
well you know things have moved on
safeguarding has improved to an extent
however could abuse that happen today
will abuse happen
you know this year next year the answer
unfortunately is yes
in that there's certain things which are
not in place mandatory reporting
accountability and what we really need
from the report today is that not only
have we listened but we've acted on it
and to answer your question openly how
much faith do i have
and i'm holding my breath actually until
i see the report
it's a 50 50 to be frank and it's the
same for all survivors and all my
clients trust is so important to the
laws of abuse
just hope the fa haven't let them down
again
yeah derrick had just noticed there's
been nodding along with pretty much
everything you
you were you were saying that you were
saying that derek i just i just want to
know though
how how much anger do you still hold
you know in in your heart for for what
you experience i've got to say as you
know
you you've spoken very openly very
eloquently your testimony has resulted
in
and people being jailed and you should
be lauded for that as a man you should
be lauded for standing up and saying
that
but also the other aspect of being a man
sometimes is we find it difficult to let
go
of being angry and upset
yeah i echo everything that dino has
said um
we've got to learn from this and let's
not be sitting here in
five years time 10 years 10 20 years
time talking about the same things
um you know hopefully this sheldon
report which i have worked
with the qc mr sheldon on the report and
give him some recommendations as a
survivor of what we should happen
dino mentioned mandy do reporting you
know that's a crucial
bit of work that should be should be in
place um the government is obviously
looking at
power of trust which is going through
parliament at present time that will
also
help um coaches um
be be accountable for their for their
actions
but again the anger i think has gone
um you never get closure uh on the
situation even though
it's been the court and it's over you
try to get on with your life and that's
what i'm doing
um i think the frustration is more of a
word that i would use
that it's taken four years for this
report to
to be published and as survivors
i think you know we just want it out
there and hopefully mr sheldon has
i'm sure had done a job and if
if clubs or persons you want to
try to shelter loads of blame here what
we're trying to do is make sure
that football is a talisman for all
sports
as a lead in safe garden in
policies and procedures to be put in
place
not just in football in gymnastics in
swimming
in in cricket in rugby to make sure that
our children are safe
when they go out to an environment where
they want to enjoy
i didn't have that you know i was it was
a purgatory for me to play football
but my release was to play football to
release that pain
i don't want any children to suffer and
hopefully
the the fa report will highlight some of
the
failings and at that point if clubs
were wrong if things weren't in place
and
that's just not football it could be the
police authorities
it could be the education authorities
hold their hands up
and say yeah we got it wrong and move on
you know let's let's look at this and
and take ownership of it
in a way where we can take some
positivity
hopefully out of this report let's let's
well let's
keep up our fingers crossed uh dino
nochebelli i hope you don't mind us
spending most of our time with
with derrick bell but thank you both
them for joining us in the program this
morning really appreciate it
thank you and if you've been
affected by any of the issues mentioned
there uh the samaritans of course
available 24
7. you can call them 116 123 or you can
email joejo
samaritans.org those contact details at
the bottom just now
but still to come on the program this
morning as some mps challenge the prime
minister's proposed policing bill
i'll be speaking to a human rights
bankster about the effects it may have
on your right to protest
a year ago in fact on march the 12th a
year ago broadway closed and none of us
could believe that broadway was actually
closing it was unheard of
and i was about to open in sister act to
start rehearsing
and we rehearsed for one day and then
everything closed down and we all
thought maybe it would be a few weeks
maybe at the most a few months
but here we are actually a year later
and it's just inconceivable that these
wonderful theaters at the heart of the
west end and the heart of every town
have been dark a lot of freelancers have
dropped
very severely through the net and that's
why these charities are
so important because if you're freelance
you go from one job to the other you're
not employed
and so many of the government help
schemes and thank goodness with the 1.57
billion that did help most theaters stay
you know so that we've still got them
when we all go back
but the freelancers have found it
particularly hard but they've really
thought outside the box and so many
people have started other little
businesses
until they can get back into the theater
and having support funds like the
theater artists fund like acting for
others
like the fleabag support fund have meant
that they could keep going until such
time as they give them
you know their jobs back and of course
theatre is not just about people like me
who appear on the stage you know it it's
so many people
so many people backstage front of house
everybody that it takes
to get a show on the road british
theater
is huge i mean with broadway it's world
beating
and people will come over here just to
come to the west end
um we need to get that back just to be
able to open the country up again
so that people will flock into the west
end and of course it's not just the west
end it's
it's the center of every single town um
and
british theater is absolutely a world
beater
the audiences are absolutely desperate
to get back
when i did pantomime down in southampton
it was glorious and yes people were
socially distant some people wearing
masks
but that feeling of love coming from
that audience and of course in may
please we can hopefully start
the uh bringing back of theater live
theater with masked socially distanced
and then hopefully
june the 21st if nothing else happens we
can open maybe joseph at the palladium
and go all the way through through to
pantomime we can get that whole world up
and running again because
it's not just me it's not just us who
miss it everybody misses it
it's part of our culture dearly missed
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast but wherever you
are welcome to
safety ridge for the ones who want to
know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that if we all
work together we can really make a
difference
to the air pollution around our schools
yeah
we should really do that
plenty of fine and warm weather for many
central and western areas today with
highs of around 16 or possibly 17
celsius for some
it will cloud over there across the
northwest later and we'll also find some
rain and quite a brisk wind
for some parts of eastern and southeast
england although that rain should clear
through the afternoon now in terms of
air quality
air quality quite good so the levels of
air pollution again remain low right
across the board and are set to stay
that way
over the next day or two as well the air
quality report
sponsored by phillips air purifiers
mps have voted in support of the
government's new policing bill
moving it a step closer to becoming law
the death of sarah everard has however
sparked a renewed focus on it
and its contents critics fear it could
be used to curtail the rights of people
to protest
while ministers say the tough
legislation will help keep people safe
and contains vital reforms uh pleased to
say we're joined on the programme by the
human rights barrister
salesh mehta salish great to see you
this morning
and we will of course have to wait to
see what final form
uh the bill the bill takes when it
enters into law
but but on the reading of the bill at
the second reading what do you make of
it
well the starting point is that we've
got to acknowledge that every politician
wants to amass as much power for
themselves
and to crush as much dissent as possible
if that's the starting point
it should be for every human rights
lawyer and every member of the public
then that's the rubric by which this
bill needs to be measured
and so the first question is is the bill
actually necessary
is the government right when it says
that the police and the home secretary
need these extra powers
and the overwhelming answer is no the
existing law is actually very
tough and gives the police and home
secretary huge amounts of powers
and the next question then is that can
this power
the extra power be abused well we don't
need
to do any investigation we know already
from the scenes at the weekend that the
police
sometimes are capable of making huge
areas of judgment
and the more power that the police have
to ban demonstrations to restrict them
the greater the chance that they're
going to make more mistakes like they
made in the
sarah everard protest and of course the
third question
is whether the powers that are being
given are proportionate
and if the answer to the first two
questions is no
not necessary then of course the the
final answer is
the powers are likely to be
disproportionate and that's what the
critics are most concerned about
i'm by no means doubting you you're a
barrister my law degree is 20 years out
of date but can you just justify the
first of your assertions there the idea
that the police
had sufficient powers look at what
happened with the extinction rebellion
protests in central london central
london
brought to a complete standstill for for
weeks on end
the police you suggest could have
prevented that
oh the existing powers could have
prevented
all the demonstrations that we've had in
the last year uh
the starting point is that the covet
restrictions
uh allowed the police those powers but
the essential point with all
demonstrations and protests is that
there's a balance
to be struck and the police normally are
the people that strike that balance
because they can
ban the demonstrations they can limit it
they can curb the number of people
and they can decide the level of
aggression
in the policing that should be applied
now of course sometimes they get it
right sometimes they get it wrong
and the example you've given there are
times when the police got it wrong
but if you look at the black lives
matter demonstrations by and large the
police got it right
and there's a tension between the right
of the public to protest and often these
protests
are either in breach of the law or in
anticipated breach of the law
and of course the right of the public
not to have nuisance not to have
uh demonstrations disrupting their life
and it's really that balance
that everyone is concerned about and the
general feeling amongst human rights
lawyers is that the balance
is out of kilter with this new bill i'm
at the risk of being slightly cheeky
just for a moment stylish isn't it the
case that human rights barristers qcs
like yourselves
will challenge any uh piece of
legislation that
seeks to amend diminish curtail
you know freedom to association freedom
of assembly
you're right and i suppose the test uh
for every bit of this sort of
legislation is
what would the home secretary have done
if the suffragette movement
was at the moment just starting would
our present home secretary
have had lots of phone calls between
herself and crested dick
over the weekend to say go in hard stop
these demonstrations
or with the home secretary and the
police were allowed the sufficient
movement
that's a good starting point and you're
right of course
barrisses like me will challenge every
uh attempt of a power grab by any
politician that's the nature of the
beast
i i'm just a final thought where might
this end up of course we've got the
we still we do not know how the
legislation will finally look but what
is your worst case scenario
the worst case scenario is that there
will be so much power given so much
discretionary power is given
and the home secretary will have amassed
to herself so much power of
subsequent legislation without scrutiny
in parliament
this bill allows the home secretary even
wider powers to legislate
on her own or through committee that's
the the worst case scenario
that people really need to be worried
about sales meta good to see you this
morning thanks for being with us
i had time for us to check in see how
the weather's looking
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
high pressure is keeping most of the
british isles fine and dry the center of
the highs around here
we've got the winds coming around that
high quite brisk at times for the east
coast where it'll feel a little chilly
and you will find some rain comes down
in the flow as well to affect some
eastern parts particularly through the
afternoon
and east anglia parts of southeast
england as well seeing some of that rain
coming in by
lunchtime elsewhere sunshine rather more
widespread
not bad in the sunshine as well highs
into the mid teens possibly
a few spots again up to 16 or 17 celsius
very nice indeed that's into the 60s
fahrenheit
cloudier though for the far northwest
later misty low cloud with a little
drizzle
and we'll still hold on to breeze and a
fair amount of cloud in the southeast
tonight as well
just the odd patch of frost in central
parts and tomorrow a quiet weather day
some rain in the east though
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you very much indeed uh
coming up in the eight o'clock hour
on sky news breakfast as we approach the
first anniversary of the country going
into lofta
find out why the business secretary
thinks now is not the time for a public
inquiry
[Music]
[Music]
so
foreign